which company do you think has done more
for the environment in America Philip
Morris or
Tesla prob probably Tesla I say Tesla
has a much lower ESG score than Philip
Morris well we should explain what that
is ESG they score your company on
environmental social governance so how
much are you helping out with the
environment social like how many women
do you have on your board how many gays
do you have on your board how many
colored people all this stuff Philip
Morris has plus rating what a great
environmental company Philip Morris
great job no it's because Elon Musk
thinks the SN ESG stands for satanic you
know right now if you wanted to go be
nominated for an Oscar what percentage
of your employees need to be part of a
lgbtq community Native Americans
disability black if you don't you cannot
be nominated which means almost every
single movie in the history of oscars
that won an Oscar would have never won
with today's guidelines